here just let him go give me one reason  why I shouldn't do it I'm drawing a  blank what I think you should shoot me  you'd really be doing me a favor  cancer tumor the size of a peach he's on  to us Oh guys just give us the money or  what or he's gonna shoot you in the net  want to shoot a guy with cancer  grandma Mikulski who cares he doesn't  have cancer you idiots really bone this  thing first of all you gotta wait till  she gets my pants off and then you got  to give me a chance to run that's how  you get the money and you never drop the  con you never break die with the lie and  why'd you come up here if you're so  smart professional curiosity and I like  boobs I figured it was a win-win